i'm just gonna warn you off top i'm a
terrible interviewer i forget everything
yeah i get nervous to go blind
screw this is gonna be great i'm telling
you i think they think you're highly of
us
right
[Music]
well in the spirit of that how do you
feel
i feel uh i feel
thanks for asking that i mean i feel
just in general and not
just with the awards just like add it in
but just in general you know
well i had a tough time i had a tough
time with um
like jumping back into what
is partly performative right like
performance really took a stark
like i just saw performance
a little bit clearer for what it was you
know i was answering questions at the
beginning of the
of the press tour and i was like i
thought i was relaxed
and then um we went through some stuff
during this pandemic
like really scary things and um
after that happened i was like oh
there's another level of awareness
and i keep sitting into that pocket and
like you're like oh wow like i was
still performing and that is something
maybe that we all do
this is such a random thought but like i
connected to kind of your performance of
like watching you
as billy the thing that stood up to me
the most was i was like
wow and and and please tell me if i'm
projecting but like i was like whoa
that is the pain of a person who knows
something that nobody else knows
oh my god you hit it on the head in a
way that i have not in this entire press
tour
no one has said that in this entire tour
that secret i guess that's
the difference between two artists
no it was absolutely that you know i i
always say
billie holiday was a 20 21 person living
in the 30s 40s and 50s you know what i
mean it was just
and people it goes to the question
people you know her activism do you
think you know like that's what she
wanted to sacrifice for activism do you
think she
knew she was an activist and i was like
no
and maybe she she knows what no one else
knows and i think she also knows and is
willing to speak about what no one else
is willing to admit you know
they're not one person back then at the
time truly i think
it's culturally acceptable lynching
people but
generally speaking it's it's a horrific
act right you're doing it
you want to inflict pain and shame and
you know and and on a person so i think
also
the pain of someone who's willing to
talk about
you know um what's happening and a pain
from someone who's not willing to live
you know one of the things she would
always say in her life was
i don't want to be anybody's damn maid
you know what i mean and
um and so i think that it was just the
pain of a
black queer woman saying i want to live
freely and i realize
it's kind of probably cost me my life
basically
um but um but i'm you know willing to do
it anyway so
yeah no you're totally under you totally
totally understand that and
that's what you did i was it was so
incredible watching you because i was
like you almost have to do nothing
like you know what i mean like you feel
funny you sound like lee right now lee's
like literally
this was our running joke on set like he
would come in and he'd be like okay
cut it in half cut it in half then you
cut it in half cut it out and then he'd
like
do nothing like oh all right cool yeah
and so it's it's almost like a madman's
you know kind of
kind of try the willingness to sort of
sacrifice maybe family or whatever to
like
but but there's also this idea that i'm
helping them like i'm helping them and
they won't see it now but they will so
i don't know i wonder how much of i just
wonder your thoughts on it and
that's because i loved it but oh i
appreciate it no i mean like
you're talking on like back to that idea
of just
awareness right like yeah um you know
jacob
like trey's character like he's doing
what he thinks is supposed to
be the right thing and so
he is vindicated in some way because he
has some sort of purity of
of intention you know so
i think i think about that a lot of just
like um
yeah i don't want to belabor this point
but like i really did appreciate
how your performance
didn't need to sell it was just
it lived into your body and like that's
when you know
i deeply respect that work because you
know
you did so much of the internal work
that was really beautiful thank you and
likewise
just in general i think this is my
question to actors in general it's like
how did you go from i don't know how
long you prepared so really first how
long
do were you preparing for and then
secondly coming out of it going right
into a pandemic then going right into
award season with all this stuff like
are you still processing jacob are you
still yeah
okay that's what i mean right like the
journey hasn't stopped with this movie
because i still have to talk about it i
still have to like
reflect it back it reflects back to me
based on like what the outside world
perceives
right yeah and that's kind of like this
moment right is that like i think if we
were out there
shaking hands and like you know
schmoozing and doing the thing and like
talking to people and really getting
people
one-on-one talking to us it would have
might it maybe
would have felt more immersive um and i
don't know
whether that would have been a good
thing or a bad thing but for me i was
like there's an
outside understanding of who i am and
then there's
me just as a dad waking up like deep
bags under my eyes
you know what i mean and like trying to
be a good husband and um trying to be
present
but like failing every day and so like
you juxtaposed that
to like the nomination for an oscar and
you're like
i don't i don't know what i feel like a
bum
like a regular
there's one corner that's like
yeah that's amazing well i mean i think
about that a lot too because like
you know i i'm sure you've been given so
many of the same questions over and over
and i get that like people need to
understand and
um people need to be able to write about
it or
put in something packageable so that
they can deliver it but
yeah of course um it's so much more
complex and
it makes me think about like i'm curious
about like because i had the similar
thing i knew i heard that you were
reluctant
to take the role and i'm not curious
about like why you're reluctant
because i can i feel like i understand
to some degree but
more like what happened after you tipped
like what happened after you're like all
right i'm gonna take it like i'm just
gonna do it
you know for me it was it was there was
a lot of factors and i am a very
spiritual person which i want to talk
about with your movie as well too
because
between you and all amazing and like
there are a lot of listening listeners
to her not just for her tone of voice
but for where she is you know
actually in her mind is she sober is she
is she high is she
she drunk is she tired is she happy
is she and listening to where she's at
like the things that she like there's
one clip okay sorry i'm wrong with it
but
oh no her when she's in like uh she just
wear bands you know like rehearsal
and they're asking her about the set
list you know i mean they're like 13
songs you know so we
13 what are we doing for 13 songs we
need something whatever and she goes
yeah and i need a cigarette you know to
be like you know just funny those things
and they're like well 13 and well take
off that 13. i hate that song i hate
and really it's funny because you know
you listen to it and go
clearly she's irritated you know what i
mean and she's saying she doesn't want
13 but three what she's really saying
she does not want to be talking to this
person like you can hear
what i mean so just all of that all you
know the stuff that you know the stuff
that you do and it's
right like i mean like we all we do that
too where you're just like oh i know
that person or
like the internet does that really
obviously now where it's like you can
get the starter pack
of everybody you can be like oh that
person's this person it's like they're
not
they're like a deep you know they have
multitudes
and so you know i had to reconcile
with the way that i understood my
parents generation
because i was talking about them and
they hadn't been really
you know humanized i think a lot of
portrayals about them are usually like
embedded in a little bit of shame where
um
not they're it's not shameful of them
it's just more like the concept
of a first generation immigrant for a
second generation kid
is like this weird gate you gotta pass
through to be like
hey like i want to feel american but
like this didn't allow me to and like
you look at them as concepts um
sometimes because
the language too and so i just confront
that
i had to look there in my face to be
like do i see my dad
in his fullness i feel like i do but do
i and
i think touching that stuff was really
scary because i knew i was gonna be
touching something that was
really precious to a lot of people
and um that freaked me out because
um you know i'm also like
i don't like being not liked
[Music]
yeah yeah he got builds up that skin
right i mean
for me you brought up faith and in my
faith something we talk about is
being refined by fire you know what i
mean and so it's very interesting i see
what you mean about craving those
moments because sometimes if it feels
too
comfortable too easy too safe or i'm
just killing it all the time
those moments especially as you get
older you begin to realize how
much they you meet them you know what i
mean you're not actually developing i
think into a
well you you need a human being and
um you know maybe people won't be able
to like understand that and like contain
it in a
in a article or something but
the power of that is i think very
profound of just like remembering that
we all
are human it really helped to ground me
you know for the first time in quite a
while since the movie
this is a this is the crux at the crux
of my identity now in this season
so similar but completely different
whereas
and that's kind of what we've been doing
the light sort of exposes things right
and his healing and it's
all these things and so that really just
kind of
made me realize all right this is who i
am in this season that's
part of who i'm supposed to be you know
and
and and then it align aligns with what
we've kind of been doing with the movie
and shedding light and you know
different things so i i hope that
answered your question
no no that's not i mean i'm interested
in all this stuff i mean
that's exactly how i feel too which is
like it
but it also does take a bravery that i
that i think is so great
of being able to kind of throw away
the baggage of the past you know crazy
like my friend was saying it the other
day she was i was like yeah that she's
not
here anymore you know what i mean of
course always some version of ourselves
right we're constantly evolving
constantly growing
and she was like oh my gosh she's like
that's so sad and i was and i kind of
looked at her and i was like yeah
like she and i realized it's a more i it
i
am mourning you know what i mean be and
i realized that i
couldn't find me or whoever that old
person was
when i was on set and lee asked me he's
like okay give me andrew i don't want
billy for this scene give me andra
and i had a moment like you i just
started falling and i
was i felt so uncomfortable and out of
my skin desperately inside myself
trying to find then i felt like i was
trying to copy mannerisms of myself you
know what i mean it's pretty weird it
was like
watching a person and then i felt like i
was doing an impersonation of andrew day
right like
and my my friend my creative director
was on set with me like
oh she was helping assist me and she was
like that was the most bizarre [ __ ] ever
i was like i was waiting to see
the person that i knew and then so
that's the moment that i knew and so
yeah
it really got to a point where i had to
grieve not only
billy you know i mean even though she's
never fully gonna be gone but
i had to grieve it was like it felt
forced upon me like i didn't know that
you you know you didn't tell me before
that it went embarking on this role i
would have to say goodbye to that person
i i
i wish you would have told me you know
and let me know you know so
um yeah so it definitely feels like a
loss of them
that gives me chills that gives me
chills because i i
i i feel that
very much that's how like
i and i wonder if if it's if it's
yes it is saying goodbye to that that
older person that old person but it's
also like
like an expansion so that yeah
absolutely right like you don't have to
hold on to that last
it's just love you now yeah exactly and
that's that's the thing i was gonna say
too it's like you grieve
because i didn't was like was unaware
that it was gonna happen i was not
prepared really i felt
you know what i mean but i do know like
but i
i'm getting to a place now it's it's
it's almost a bit of a celebration you
know what i mean it was scary at first
and it was sad at first until i realized
like
oh i don't have to go back to get that
other person because
this movie this person really i'm
pointing here because there's a picture
of her
but really holiday the all of these
things i believe
for my faith god is using these things
to inform who i'm supposed to be in this
season so it's like
i'm finally getting to a place where it
feels a little less of a
fight of like okay i think that that's a
huge huge part of it so
i i also wanted to ask you something as
well too about you
um when you first you know um
got the script right was it did you did
you first hear like just about the
concept or were you just sent a script
first
well well so uh yeah they just sent me
the script
um i knew isaac because isaac is my
wife's
cousin but we never really talked
before nor did we really talk about
working
he i didn't even know he was directing
anymore and then
um we share an agent um and she was like
here's a script that isaac wrote i'm
like what
so i read it and i was yeah finish your
question i'm sorry we were gonna ask oh
that that's
that's that no that answer is actually
part of my question as well
but but just when you first got it like
was it sort of
were you right away like i am in this is
me or worried because i know you said
you had hesitation
and or was it like i really wanted like
you know what work kind of did you
guys do on jacob or were you really
involved at all in that yeah
and fully realized by the time you got
it you know well it connects to that
statement you made about just kind of
like
we're locked into the view of like the
white male
um patriarchy i read it it felt
liberated because you know you know
i i think you know the depictions of
racism
in it are at times real uh meaning like
the ways in which the subtlety of how it
works and just the misunderstandings and
like
the banana like just the benign nature
of those interactions
um but you know we weren't it wasn't
that the script was ignoring
that racism happens to people or asian
people or
anyone it was just more like this is a
story about
this family and when they go home
they're not thinking about you
yeah exactly i love that's what i loved
about it i when i say tunnel vision i
was like
they were locked in they were talking
all the way in exactly right it's like
we're not even going to let you in our
story because we're not thinking about
you
i love it and it was so beautiful and
that's why i feel like i think it's
grabbing people so much it is a fully
realized
family these are fully realized people
you know as individuals and as a unit is
incredible and i think the important
part then at the end of it all is that
like
sure it could be like we're not thinking
about you but also
it's we're not thinking about you so now
you can access us
yes absolutely so how how long were you
preparing for this role
i sorry i i i feel bad sometimes i have
such elementary questions
[Music]
we started doing we started knowing that
it was going to be made
like december january of 2019
2018 going into 2019
and then i knew i knew we were starting
in the summer so i had like a whole
you know four months to just think about
it
you know and and you know i'm lucky too
because like
i'm also living a dad life and i'm also
living a life where
my wife needs to has to sacrifice for
what is you know um you know i'm
i can justify it in my head to be like
i'm doing this for the family and
it is i am but also you know
she's holding up the whole thing you
know
you know so um
you could i could draw from certain
things that i could
you know understand about just like i
think when it clicked for me was i was
like oh i
am my father like i am wow that's crazy
yeah i don't know if you felt that same
way about like
like at some point were you like oh i am
billy right absolutely
no i you know it's funny because people
actually when it clicked for me
i mean i don't even know if it clicked
earlier
it just kind of just like moves through
you and like yeah it's like you don't
really
it just it's how it was a gradual thing
obviously because like i said the time
sort of that had passed you know so it
was sort of this uh
you know everybody's like when were you
really like i'm billy and i'm like i
don't know it just wasn't slipping into
her you know i mean he was like
constantly just a slope you know of into
into her or i guess ascension rather
maybe into her but
but um but i will say there's a moment
you know when we are
um when we're on set and you're in
wardrobe you know and they ask you you
know wardrobe obviously
you know especially when you're doing a
period you know you know so
like a different period then yeah
there's something about it but it wasn't
it didn't feel i think everybody thinks
it's this aha moment of like oh my gosh
okay now i feel like really now i'm like
i've been feeling like her before you
know what i mean i'd be [ __ ]
she's on my new record you know to me
like you know she's imprinted in my
family and my relationships and my
you know there are people who only know
me on this side and you know
and that's familiar to them me as billy
is familiar to them you know
um so it was more like okay there i
am you know does that make sense it felt
like that turning around to see it was
like oh there i am like it just feels
like
the physical sort of caught up to what
you're feeling internally already
i feel parallel to jacob's journey as an
actor as myself
which was like i was so busy trying to
control it and sweet
and and make it what i thought it was
that i forgot to
be aware of what was happening because
the third take i just go and i just
i'm in it and i look over and i look at
yeti
who plays monica and she's such an
incredible actor
and she's bawling and stopping for the
third take
in a row like way where i was like oh
that's real
one is a testament to her skill and and
and
and just how great she is of an actor
but also i was made deeply aware i was
like oh
jacob doesn't cry here monica
cries here yeah he's been holding the
family
i was just thinking oh you know
literally hearing you talk about it and
thinking about that is
thinking about the scene oh my god this
is so i now have goosebumps because of
you speaking about that because even as
you're talking through it
you're telling me i'm like i'm trying to
cry and i'm trying to and i'm like
thinking about something
but that's jacob like that is him you
know what i mean he is that
so even the idea that okay i just need
to let it go and be present but that and
that's still him
thinking about it needs to everything is
this thought
force us so it's very interesting that
that
thought process i mean anyway the
performance was phenomenal but not just
because of
the crying or for the t because you are
so you're
so funny even you describing it you were
so locked in that that's exactly you
gave jacob that's exactly what
i feel like if if if he was on set
acting and playing himself he would have
probably been super obsessed about
emotion now and same [ __ ] it has to be
this and it has to be so
that's actually really it's so funny how
those
those things can sort of net you you
know what i mean like
this the stuff you think you got to
overcome or the stuff you think you have
to like even the you thinking you have
to overcome it is actually netting you
the person you know
it just it's all it's right there it
tells you yeah yeah absolutely but
why is it so hard though like i keep
thinking like we could have this
conversation and then probably if i go
on another set i'ma overthink
every [ __ ] thing
[Laughter]
well steven obviously as you can tell i
have so enjoyed talking to you
and again just the movie is amazing your
performance is amazing you were just
you know so tapped in it's a way better
much deeper way to describe it than that
but
um but you were amazing i was so moved
and
it has been truly a joy and hopefully
this is not the last time that we do
this no
can't be uh andrew thank you for this
conversation and
um you you crushed it so hard i
i'm so um thank you for your performance
too and
um thanks for this conversation
thank you let's do it again
you